today I thought we go over CPM the very
first operating system for
microcomputers quite a significant thing
history wise but why don't we use it
today is it a bit like dose it is it is
a lot like dose I would use the analogy
of its beat of X whereas das sees VHS
for our younger viewers VHS and Betamax
are types of video tape sometimes not
necessarily the best thing technically
wins out yes yeah I mean the market
forces ended up choosing the cheaper
option that's that's often how things
work you can't talk about CPA without
talking about gary kildall he's the guy
that votes CPM by all accounts is one of
the nicest most genuine federally
helpful guys in the computing world ever
is that necessarily the best basically
SMED though you studied to be a best
teacher and he was a math teacher but
near Nereid after Silicon Valley there
he got hold of one of the until for
double o for micro processors when they
first come out its oldest he's great for
meth we could do things on it obviously
a four bit process is relatively limited
but once he was able to get hold of the
a table right he messed about with it
done some things had said oh we can have
a programming language for this intel
said well no this is just gonna go in
you know control things like washing
machines and stuff like that why would
you want a programming language for it
he developed PLM programming language
for microcomputers on the a table right
if it will if I could write a program at
language for I could I'd use that
language
Ed's write an operating system which is
which is where CPM came from a
significant thing there really is that
for bloggers computers there was no
operating system this was back in the
Wild West days where if you if you build
your own computer you've any rogue
software that was very much your only
machine you could have just swap file
with somebody else from would have won
by code on your machine or whatever yeah
was it like to die you rare right yeah
I've got a little shady I could copy
these files here's some JPEGs you can
have a look at now you've got none of
that everybody was completely unique
what Gary buddies to do with CPM was to
standardize on
the whole La Cueva system except for the
very very Hardware specific BIOS stuff
kind of beyond Polti stuff it's not just
a case of rewriting the software to work
on this machine or that machine it's a
case of just some software visions for
CPM will run on any machine that runs
CPM the the only thing that's got to be
unique is the the BIOS the the basic
input/output system
so effectively CPM is made up of three
three separate layers we got the BIOS
which talks direct to the hardware
that's the thing that actually
interfaces directly to the chips to the
video controller to the disk controller
or whatever you they've got the B dos
which is the basic disk operating system
that talks to the BIOS and that allows
it to read the right to the disks and do
do whatever it needs to do then you've
got the CCP command control processor so
that that takes the instructions that
you put into it that talks to the B dos
to be dos then interfaces with the
hardware and once bunch of program does
whatever it needs to do but apart apart
of the BIOS everything else is standard
so it will run odd on any any machine
that word CPM which in its heyday
there's up to about 3000 different types
of a she'd read CPM the first thing to
say with regard to toss is CPM came out
before dos that was already well
established that was the market leader
well I be able decided to join in the
game and they wanted to be out there old
microcomputer they approached Microsoft
of Bill Gates obviously he's got like
soft basic so he said yes we could
supply that he also said yes they could
supply the operating system as well
which Microsoft at the time didn't have
IBM also approached Digital research ie
gary kildall there this is the stuff of
legend you bill quite often here face
that gary kildall is the guy that was
off lied where'd I be a became da kid
there's a few different versions of the
story
I don't think knows what
said exactly what happened there but
effectively what it sounds like you know
yeah go from a few different sources he
was a qualified pilot he used to fly off
to his customers delivering software and
stuff like that he was actually out
flying that day he had his wife answered
the phone and I be able said oh yeah we
would like you to sign this
non-disclosure agreement we need to talk
to you about they said the other and she
said well no you need to talk to Gary
he's out flying can you come back
another day
so the meantime yes they talked to
Microsoft Microsoft say yeah we could
because we could supply this for you so
it was looking like digital research was
going to lose the chance to quote for
supply their operating system what what
Microsoft they'd had to do was find an
operating system because they didn't
have one that was this this guy that
kind of got some of the upper body in
there that looked that look good enough
so Microsoft made him an offer I bought
Paul his his operating system for
$50,000 because Microsoft had it told
you there was reselling it to IBM so
they even got in touch with IBM said
yeah here we go we've got this operating
system so I'd be able oh yeah great we
would call that PC DOS because we make
it a PC
this is gonna be PC dos we're digital
research looked at they said well there
might be some copy white features day
looks like you've copied what we have
already had on the market for years
there were those threats of lawsuits
stuff like that in the end
IBM turned around and said well we don't
really want to loss so he could get all
messy what about we offer both options
so digital research was okay yeah we can
live without yeah we yeah going up in a
fair fight we know we've got a better
product so yes yeah yeah we were more
than happy to drop the lawsuits and you
can supply both operators or the option
of both operating systems the only thing
that IBM had had told digital research
is that they was effectively giving it
away
Microsoft ms-dos I think those charges
have not $40 or if you wanted CPM you
could pay two on
50 dollars but he was down to the public
to decide so yeah the public could go
with whatever option they wanted yet
does the public want to pay an extra two
hundred dollars well the fact that we've
yeah most machines nowadays are
windows-based kind of kind of answers
that these effectively are your biddable
CPM applications though there's a video
recently which mentioned the eight word
processor or the IDI word processor I
should I should say yes it's it's
definitely the IDI processor so that's
that one's under CPM so if you're
familiar with you using your word word
processors one line at a time that's
that's a fantastic option to use it was
probably about the best that there was
back in the day I've tried it I could
follow instructions but it's not not the
easiest thing to use it really isn't
what about you use these a compact flash
as the disk storage so CPM could
recognize up to 16 individual disks so
the compact flash has been segregated
into 16 different partitions in there so
hence we could see drive ABC etc we've
got a paintable warm got a cpu 64 K of
web clock module 0 input output and then
I've generated a video through a little
wild peopIe that's just pump it out HDMI
for thee weather daus was a copy of CPM
was actually decided in the courts in
2002 I believe but it was failed that
yes there was there was some code that's
taken directly from the source code of
CPM the guy that thought that he he was
very clever he'd changed a few bits I
was still of having a routine called
white disk you know he'd have a routine
called disk right and one or two other
little tiny tiny changes there but they
at the time claimed that was different
but yeah in the courts in 2002 that was
all settled and it was proven that CPM
was was the widget also effectively
today any computer that while
stas is funny CPA there's still some
some of that code in there gary kildall
wasn't too pleased about the fact that
he'd been taken to the cleaners
effectively he was I think I think it's
fair to say he was quite bitter about
this for for the rest of his life which
unfortunately wasn't all that much
longer after various incidences babies
broke up he became a drinker had ended
up dying in 1992 I believe
or to keyboard that people are going to
get all excited about possibly they will
it is an original cherry keyboard from
the the late eighties mid mid to late
eighties cherry keyboard yeah or
something like that there was an append
command that simply said add some more
text and you could add a bunch of